continuing our team coverage reaction
from people in our community who were
watching the verdict
as it was read madison kimbrough joining
us live from downtown las vegas now
with some of that local reaction madison
yeah today was a monumental day for
george floyd his family and the country
as former minneapolis police officer
derek chauvin was convicted
of murder and manslaughter now this
explosive case triggered worldwide
protest and violence
including right here in las vegas i
spoke to people in the downtown las
vegas area right after the verdict was
read
here's what they had to say you know
when this first case
first started last year was emotional
for a lot of people
particularly myself because i'm a mom of
three black sons who happen to be in
college
and so justice is being served with this
verdict
it was unfair that that man lost his
life for something so petty
i think it personally could have been
things could have happened different
there were so many officers there they
could have held them down without
actually
doing what they did
you may have been watching coverage in
some other cities as there have been
peaceful gatherings
both before and after the verdict was
read so far no reports of any rallies at
this moment
and we are hearing plans of a peaceful
gathering later this evening on the
strip so we're going to look out for
that
reporting live from downtown las vegas
madison kimbrough
8 news now